i feel like my entire life i've
struggled a bit with
being the loudest person in the room
standing up for yourself so i think this
whole experience getting to be an
executive producer it's helped me a lot
with that
[Music]
my name is miranda cosgrove i'm an
actress and i'm also the executive
producer of my show icarly
when it came about that we were maybe
going to do a revival of icarly the show
i did when i was little and they said
that i could be an executive producer on
it i was super excited about it because
when i did the original icarly i didn't
have any creative control so i just
thought this is going to be a whole
different experience and it was
something that really excited me
at first i was a little scared because i
was like oh my gosh this is going to be
so much work i'm going to be doing so
many things that i've never done before
and am i going to do a good job i think
parts of it i i knew how it worked from
doing it when i was young but a lot of
it i just had to kind of learn on the
fly and it's just been such a rewarding
experience
with this new version of icarly there's
a little girl on the show named jaden
and i totally see myself in her like
when she's on set she takes all the
notes and is trying her best to just do
what everybody is looking for all these
adults are looking for but because i
know how that feels i feel like i try
really hard to make sure her voice is
heard even though she's a kid
she still is an artist and she's still a
comedian and she's a huge part of what
the character ends up looking like in
the show
young people do come up to me sometimes
and they'll be like i want to act and
how did you get into it and how should i
do it and i always tell them like you
gotta do what actually feels good to you
like you gotta be yourself you can't
change yourself to try to get a part or
something like you have to be you and
you have to feel good about it i think
that took me a while to learn just
because when you start auditioning at a
really young age and you're pretending
to be all these different characters and
you're trying to get parts and things
that can kind of make it hard to figure
out exactly who you are so yeah i'd say
just always like follow your instincts
your gut instincts and really listen to
your heart even though that does sound
cheesy it's totally true
[Music]